the movie opens up with our protagonist
David Ames who wakes up in the morning
in his luxurious apartment he's quite
obsessed with his appearance as many
wealthy and attractive people tend to be
David is the son of a successful writer
and business person and takes pride in
his wealth and Status he smiles a lot
and laughs like a maniac giving us an
early glimpse into what Scientology is
doing to his brain the same day
something very unusual happens as David
steps out of his apartment in the heart
of New York City he quickly realizes
that something is a mess the bustling
city streets are eily empty devoid of
people or any sign of life even the
usually busy roads are completely silent
without any sign of moving Vehicles this
strange and unsettling situation
immediately makes David feel uneasy so
he gets out of his fancy car and does
what Tom Cruz always does he starts
running he runs through the usually
crowded and Lively Times Square he's so
perplexed by the absence of any sign of
life that he begins to shout out loud
hoping to find someone or something that
can explain this bizarre occurrence
suddenly David wakes up in his bed again
in the background he seems to be talking
to a psychologist but his words are hard
to make out he mentions he used to be a
confident businessman before something
happened surprisingly as he gets out of
bed a beautiful woman can be seen beside
him Des reveals that they are having a c
casual relationship though the girl
requests David stay with her he says
he'll call her later gives her a
trademark unhinged smile and leaves the
house next when David drives through the
city again everything is back to normal
with people all around he picks up his
friend Brian and they talk about his
love life we find out that the woman
from David's bed is Julie Johnny and
even though they're physically involved
they're not in a romantic relationship
Brian also mentions that Julie is the
girl of his dreams and advises David to
treat her with respect David says he
won't then almost gets them hit by a Mac
Truck and then they both laugh because
they're Bros when David gets to his
office his secretary fills him in on
important stuff and tells him that he's
running late for a board meeting David
then heads to the meeting room and
humorously compares the board members to
the Seven Dwarves because they all have
unique personalities and because Tom
Cruz is short and he's projecting in a
flashback we see David's childhood where
adults are jealous of his future
inheritance his parents tragically died
in a car crash caused by drunk driving
leaving him their Fortune however his
father never truly accepted David's fear
of heights the story then shifts to a
place that looks like a prison where
David is talking to a man who's probably
his psychologist mcab David doesn't seem
happy and denies any involvement in
murder charges it's revealed that after
his parents' died he became very wealthy
but he also had some unresolved problems
reluctantly David agrees to talk about
his situation with the psychologist in
another flashback we go to a birthday
party at David's house his friend Brian
introduces him to a beautiful woman
named Sophia during the party David Gets
a warning from his father's friend tip
nice about some board members trying to
take his company from him ignoring this
David spends time with Sophia showing
her his fancy living space which
includes another luxurious apartment
inside his apartment they also talk
about a famous painting called Vanilla
Sky just then Julie spots them together
so David asks Sophia to pretend they're
having a serious conversation to keep
her away following this David and Sophia
go to a private office and have a long
talk back in the prison-like place David
keeps talking to mccab sharing his
feelings about Sophia he admits he's
attracted to her and wants to keep their
relationship casual but he hopes for
something more in the future macabe
who's been married for a long time
struggles to fully understand David's
experiences as a single guy inside the
prison a guard seems to really dislike
David and watches him closely following
this David continues his story he and
Sophia went to her place where they
talked all night although they appear
very close they don't have a romantic
relationship or get physically intimate
we also learn that Sophia lives a simple
life as an artist who moved to New York
to follow her dreams the next morning as
David walks out of Sophia's apartment
Juliana pulls up beside him she abruptly
asks his night with Sophia went she then
manages to make him feel guilty about
neglecting her and eventually persuades
him to get into her car once inside the
car it becomes evident that Juliana is
obsessively in love with David she's
also jealous about him getting closer to
Sophia in a fit of rage she starts
driving recklessly speeding through busy
city streets fearing for their safety
David attempts to stop the car by
telling Juliana that he loves her
however instead of stopping she drives
the car off a bridge in an attempt to
harm both of them tragically Juliana
does not survive the crash back in the
present David shares that after the car
accident he was in a coma for a long
time and had serious injuries like a
broken jaw and a shattered arm while he
was out of it the board had already
taken over his business tip offered to
help him get control back but warned
about who could be trusted David also
mentions that after this he started
avoiding social interactions and had
bored meetings over video call in the
next scene David secretly follows Sophia
embarrassed to reveal his disfigured
face to her he then meets with a group
of top plastic surgeons to fix his
injuries but they can't offer a good
solution the only thing they can suggest
is a facial prosthetic David isn't happy
with this suggestion so he offers to
make them all level six laser lotuses
but they still can't do it so he yells
at them angrily afterward despite his
doubts about his appearance David
decides to show him himself to Sophia he
goes to her dance studio and her
reaction is a mix of feelings she gets
emotional after seeing him and mentions
about being chased Away by his guards
when she came to see him David clears
the confusion and gathers the courage to
ask her out and surprisingly she agrees
later at night when David meets Sophia
at a club he's shocked to see his friend
Brian with her both of them seem
uncomfortable with David's prosthetic
facial mask soon Sophia walks away from
the table making an excuse David Avid
then talks to Brian wondering why he's
with Sophia in response he says that she
called him herself this confuses David
and as a result he gets upset with his
friend as they get into an argument
Brian expresses how he misses the old
David and is disappointed with the
changed version David says he misses
when Brian's name was Earl feeling down
and struggling emotionally David tries
to numb his feelings with alcohol mixing
it with his prescribed medication this
gets him really drunk couldn't impaired
he starts talking to Sophia about the
night they first met making her
uncomfortable Sophia and Brian then
realize that something is seriously
wrong with David as they leave the bar
David continues to act strangely he
wallows in self-pity and even insults
his best friend he accuses Brian of
saying something that upset Julie and
caused the car accident he was in David
also seems jealous suspecting that
Sophia and Brian might be in a romantic
relationship though he doesn't say it
outright after the group goes their
separate ways David ends up passing out
on the sidewalk the next morning Sophia
finds David in bad shape on the side of
the road she accuses him of seeking
sympathy which has strangely worked on
her she then helps him to his house and
along the way admits that she fell for
the David that she first met and it
still affects her back to the
conversation with mcabe David tells him
about how he used to feel like he
deserved Sophia's trust but now he's
unsure while in prison he can't stop
stop drawing pictures of Sophia mcab
mentions that the guards heard David
call out for someone named Ellie whom he
can't remember they also talk about the
doctor's fixing David's face but he's
too scared to look at it however David
reveals that he lets someone take off
his mask for the first time and she told
him it was perfect next we see David
Sophia and Brian having a night out at a
restaurant during the evening David
notices a man keeping an eye on him he
believes that it is the same man who was
present during his face operation
however he also thinks that he's merely
hallucinating then David has a terrible
nightmare about his face getting scarred
again he goes back to sleep and feels
someone hugging him thinking it's Sophia
he hugs the person back but it turns out
to be Julie he panics and ties her up
demanding to know what she did with
Sophia the girl keeps saying that she is
Sophia but David doesn't believe her and
calls the police to his surprise instead
of arresting Julie the police take David
in for questioning at the police station
tip shows up and bails David out he then
brings out photos of Julie with a
bruised face but claims that David hurts
Sophia seeing this our guy gets confused
as he doesn't remember hitting Sophia at
all to make matters worse he keeps
experiencing hallucinations hearing
bells and seeing people who may or may
not be real he's repeatedly told to wake
up making him unsure if he's in a dream
or reality which is how I felt when I
watched his appearance on Oprah outside
the jail Brian is waiting and he
confronts David for hurting Sophia the
latter insists that it was Julie but
Brian angrily says that she died a long
time ago in the car accident this leaves
David puzzled and he accuses Brian of
being a part of the seven dwarves of the
board at this point he doesn't know who
to trust or if he's truly awake after
this David goes for a drink alone and
encounters the same man from the
restaurant Edmund Edmund claims s
there's an explanation for everything he
is facing and offers to help he also
claims that David has some kind of
control over the world and the people in
the bar David tests this by asking
everyone to be quiet and to his surprise
they immediately stop and stare at him
that's not control David's on peyote
back at the prison David talks about
Edmund and maab asks if he can
distinguish between dreams and reality
after this David begins to recall the
meeting he had with Edmund and a
contract that he signed but he admits
he's unsure about what's real David
mentions that someone died during an
experiment but the memory is fuzzy next
David Goes to Sophia's apartment and
discovers something shocking everything
in the house including photos on the
fridge are related to Julie David asks
her who she is and she insists that
she's Sophia she suggests that they
restart their Affair and be together
again however David is is terribly
confused and refuses to believe this is
the woman he's been in love with moments
later Julie goes into the bathroom and
when she comes out she's now Sophia but
then in David's recurring nightmare
while he is having intercourse with
Sophia she transforms back into Julie
David is like this is amazing but he
feels his sanity slipping and decides to
smother the woman beneath him with a
pillow but when he gets the job done he
starts panicking in the present mcabe
tells David that he believes his guilt
over how he treated Julie and her
accident led to his deranged behavior
and hallucinations David then admits to
killing Sophia during a moment of mental
instability hearing this mcab wants to
help him in his trial but needs more
ansers later at night David watches a TV
report about Benny the dog and the
cryofreeze program for Life Extension he
suddenly remembers something and calls
mcab back together they head to a
company called life extension with a
court order and pretend to be one of
their potential customers at the
facility David encounters a receptionist
he vaguely remembers from his past she
guides him through a hallway where
people share their reasons for choosing
cryofreezing it all seems odd they then
meet Rebecca Dearborn who explains life
extension and the lucid dream option
David realizes he's heard all of this
before in reality or dreams as Rebecca
speaks David figures out that he's not
truly living his life but but is trapped
in his own mind he panics and rushes
downstairs finding an empty Lobby much
like the deserted streets of New York
City at this moment David realizes that
it's all a bad dream and starts crying
he then yells out for tech support until
an empty elevator opens inside is the
man he's been looking for Edmund Ventura
who's from The Oasis project once called
life extension Edmund starts explaining
things to David he reveals that they met
over 150 years ago when life extension
was established the lucid dreams didn't
start for David until the night when he
fell asleep on the sidewalk the morning
Sophia found him was the start of it all
Edmond explains that they erased most of
David's life and memories from before to
give him a more peaceful existence after
this David wants to know what really
happened and Edmond reveals that after
the club incident Sophia never came to
get him he woke up on his own and never
saw her again David fell into loneliness
and depression which led to his body
being put in a suspended State here it
is revealed that it was David who
contacted Edmund and signed a contract
with life extension he then committed
The Unthinkable by consuming a lot of
pills Edmund also mentions that David's
best friend Brian held a 3-day memorial
for him and Sophia was there hearing
this David becomes happy to learn that
he didn't kill Sophia Edmund then
mentions that now it's up to David to
decide whether to wake up and live in
the real world with other people or stay
in his his lucid dream with Sophia
forever as they are conversing the two
arrive at the rooftop of the building
Edmund explains that David kept seeing
juliean his dream because somewhere in
his subconscious mind he believed
himself to be guilty right then David's
thoughts bring mccab and Brian to the
rooftop representing the two conflicting
parts of his mind they're waiting for
him to make a choice Edmund tells David
it's all up to him and that if he wants
to wake up he has to face his final fear
which is Heights he assures David that
as soon as he jumps from the building he
will open his eyes from cryonation
macabe tries his best to stop David from
jumping but the ladder replies that he
wants to live a real life and not just a
dream with the sun shining on him and
the Beautiful vanilla skies above before
he jumps David sees Sophia one more time
knowing he's Frozen and she's gone but
they hold hope to find each other again
in another life perhaps as cats what
what a stupid hope in the last scene
David turns and takes a leap from the
roof wanting to wake up from his
NeverEnding dream time slows down and
his life flashes before his eyes as he
faces the unknown he hears the words
relax David open your eyes and boom the
movie ends and though I'll be the first
to admit it didn't make any goddamn
sense it's one of my favorites of all
time nonetheless subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching m